et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Marlène qui a pas bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous secrétaire d'État
chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la vie associative en
étant sans prendre un peu plus de 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice dessert dons du
groupe Ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'Est de la France Bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
service du pays sont touchés c'est plus
de la moitié dans la région des
Hauts-de-France est-ce que le
gouvernement doit procéder à des
réquisitions alors d'abord je veux
rappeler que la première ministre qui
est en déplacement en Algérie c'est
pourtant exprimer sur le sujet en
rappelant que elle était extrêmement
vigilante avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement je vais aussi avoir un
message pour être rassurant si c'est
possible et rappeler que les tensions en
approvisionnement elles vont s'améliorer
au cours de la semaine et puis ensuite
dans les jours à venir et nous avons
donc toutes et tous une responsabilité à
avoir notamment pour tâcher de ne pas
faire stock si je puis le dire de cette
manière je sais que il peut y avoir de
l'inquiétude et je sais que ça peut être
perçu comme difficilement y compris à
être handicapant dans la vie quotidienne
mais véritablement cela devrait
s'améliorer dans la semaine dans les
jours qui suivent
à ce stade non sur le blocage parce que
je veux être complètement les sujets
dont j'ai la charge mais je veux être
complète sur la question de la
réquisition et vous dire que
effectivement le gouvernement a libéré
des stocks stratégiques de carburant et
que ça a permis de libérer environ 20%
des flux voilà ça c'est une précision
que mes collègues vous apporteraient
s'ils étaient là mais vous voyez
l'exaspération des Français qui font des
heures de queue pour faire de l'essence
et souvent on en trouve pas est-ce qu'à
un moment au gouvernement craint le
risque d'une explosion sociale mais je
vous le disais nous nous faisons tout
pour que ça s'améliore au cours de la
semaine et dans les jours à venir c'est
l'objectif qui a été donné les ministres
en charge sont vraiment mobilisés sur le
sujet il y a des discussions également
au sujet de cette entre guillemets
préventive qui sont menées la première
ministre a demandé à ce que les
discussions puissent être avancées et
donc on trouve des solutions la CGT doit
cesser les blocages des raffineries
il y a des causes assez blocages et il y
a des causes assez embouteillages et
donc oui effectivement il faut
travailler sur sur ces causes là vous
comprenez que des salariés d'un grand
groupe comme Total aussi entre
guillemets profiter des super profits
bien sûr non mais je comprends je
comprends l'idée après sur la méthode
elle peut interroger moi je suis très
attachée aux droits de grève donc il
m'appartient pas en tant que membre du
gouvernement de dire si tel grève
légitime ou ne l'est pas en revanche
c'est vrai que la méthode de greffe
préventive je mets des guillemets elle
interroge et la première ministre adore
et déjà dit qu'elle souhaitait qu'on
puisse avancer le calendrier en termes
de discussion salariale pour y apporter
des réponses et qu'on ne mette pas le
pays dans un tel état dans les images
que l'on voit et les gens qui peut-être
nous regardent ce matin et se demandent
si vont pouvoir aller travailler ou
aller chercher leurs enfants on va
parler des réformes en cours elles sont
nombreuses et c'est des sujets abordé
Edouard Philippe hier dans son interview
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France longue
interview il se démarque quand même du
gouvernement sur plusieurs points il est
plus libre que loyal Edouard Philippe
pour vous non mais moi je pense qu'elle
doit Philippe ça a été le premier
Premier ministre du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron c'était mon premier
ministre quand j'étais secrétaire d'État
rattaché à lui sur l'égalité femme homme
il a aussi sa liberté de ton mais moi
j'ai lu avec beaucoup d'attention à ses
propos je trouvais extrêmement loyal au
présent de la République au gouvernement
il soutient les mesures qui sont menées
il salue même un certain nombre de
ministres et ils partagent les objectifs
du président de la République donc je
pense que c'est
il vous trouve quand même un petit Moret
à la fois sur le timing pas assez vite
passer loin il propose même 67 ans
c'est pas un peu irritant quand on est
encore aux manettes et puis qu'on voit
son ancien Premier ministre expliqué
comment il faudrait faire
non non moi je pense que c'est sain dans
une démocratie qui est des grandes voix
avec nos alliés s'expriment que ce soit
Edouard Philippe François Bayrou et
qu'on puisse avoir des débats et moi je
vais pas je vous trouve un peu sévère
dans dans l'analyse des propos des
devoirs Philippe
il faut bouger plus il faut bouger
beaucoup sur la réforme
l'idée d'un âge de départ à 67 ans la
question de la réforme des retraites
elle faisait partie du programme et du
projet du président de la République
dans l'élection présidentielle elle sera
portée par le gouvernement il y a pas de
débat sur ce sujet donc en cela moi
j'observe qu'on ne débat plus de la
nécessité de faire une réforme et
qu'aujourd'hui on débat des paramètres
de cette réforme et je pense que c'est
heureux ça veut dire qu'on débat de
l'âge aussi puisqu'on est manuel Macron
ne parle plus des 65 ans un totem moi je
pense que sur cette réforme et pourquoi
nous n'avons pas réussi à aller au bout
dans le premier car un canal parce que
j'avais beaucoup travaillé sur la
question de la retraite des femmes avec
Edouard Philippe justement je pense
qu'on doit vraiment prendre le temps de
partager le diagnostic à la fois le
diagnostic sur la question de
l'équilibre budgétaire et le rapport du
corps en cela est très intéressant mais
pas uniquement aussi surtout les grands
enjeux de société sur la question de la
pénibilité du travail sur la question de
la retraite des femmes des carrières
hachées de l'emploi des seniors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand si on allonge
le l'âge de départ à la retraite comment
on fait alors que aujourd'hui même pour
beaucoup de femmes qui sont peu
qualifiées après 50 ou 55 ans c'est déjà
difficile sur le marché du travail alors
le fait d'aller vers le plein emploi va
nous y aider le tout le travail que nous
menons sur la formation sur la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
pour offrir des deuxième carrière va
nous y aider aussi et Olivier du socle
ministre du Travail a mis sur la table
la question du départ progressif à la
retraite qui peut aussi être une piste
que qui peut être pour vous il faut
tenir bon sur les 65 ans et que ça
figure absolument dans cette réforme ou
est-ce que ça fait partie des points sur
lesquels le gouvernement peut il doit
lâcher du laisse moi j'ai pas de totem
et pour l'instant il est trop tôt pour
le dire dans la mesure où les
consultations s'ouvrent le ministre du
Travail et d'ailleurs la première
ministre Elisabeth borne et
personnellement compliqué sur ce
chantier tous les deux Elisabeth borne
Olivier dussott ils sont très attachés à
avoir une méthode vraiment de
consultation de discussion je sais à
quel point ils ont reçu à la fois les
présidents de groupe parlementaires des
oppositions mais aussi les partenaires
sociaux ils continuent à dialoguer et
nous verrons ensuite ce que nous mettons
sur la table comme proposition mais
trouver du consensus me semble être
absolument nécessaire sur le budget à
Brice une semaine difficile s'annonce
est-ce que le 49-3 est évitable est-ce
que vous n'allez pas devoir passer en
force quand on écoutera Robert Gers ce
week-end sur la période de télévision on
a l'impression que c'est pas évitable
écoutez moi je dirais que le jeu et la
prochaine action est entre les mains de
l'opposition nous avons en face de nous
des oppositions qui nous disent
ouvertement qu'elles ne souhaitent pas
être constructive et qu'elle souhaite
voter contre le budget quoi qu'il se
passe et quel que soit les mesures qui
sont dans le projet de loi donc nous
verrons je sais que le mis du budget
Gabriel Attal nous faisait compte public
là aussi dialogue travail sans cesse
pour faire en sorte de convaincre des
parlementaires de voter ce budget qui
est un bon budget étant j'ai équilibré
qui a été travaillé avec beaucoup de
sérieux nous verrons ce qu'il en est
mais c'est vrai que si les oppositions
nous disent d'emblée coûtez nous les
débats nous intéresse pas quoi qu'il en
soit on sait qu'on votera contre la
question se pose et la question se pose
du timing aussi est-ce qu'il faut le
déclencher tout de suite ce 49-3 les
débats début de cet après-midi ou est-ce
qu'il faut attendre plusieurs jours pour
voir s'il peut y avoir des compromis
sachant qu'effectivement les oppositions
ont déjà dit qu'à voter contre nous
verrons je veux pas parler à la place du
ministre des comptes publics il y a un
débat parlementaire je suis très attaché
à la préparation des pouvoirs et donc je
veux pas moi en tant que membre du
pouvoir exécutif dire au pouvoir
législatif ce qu'il ce qu'il aura à
faire au cours des débats moi je pense
qu'il y a des éléments ce budget qui
sont extrêmement intéressants qui
reflètent les grandes priorités du
président de la République sur l'accès
aux plein emploi sur la protection des
plus fragiles sur aussi certains budgets
dans lequel il y a des économies pour
avoir un équilibre budgétaire important
mais raisonnable je trouve que c'est un
bon budget voilà le ministre des pompes
publics a amené un travail important
avec la première ministre et donc je
pense qu'il faut donner sa chance à ce
budget au moment du débat il y a des
discussions des débats au sein de votre
majorité pour savoir que faire face aux
amendements du rassemblement national 89
députés il y aura forcément des
amendements est-ce que pour vous il faut
les rejeter parce qu'ils viennent du
rassemblement national et il n'est pas
question de parle de d'examiner des
amendements du RL ou est-ce qu'il faut
les regarder s'ils sont bons ben il faut
les voter
non mais là encore ça appartient au
parlementaire de se prononcer je sais
qu'il y a rien qui en parlementaire
déteste plus clairement du gouvernement
qui vient lui dire ce qu'ils doivent
voter de surcroît sur un champ qui n'est
pas dans son ministère moi je veux
regarder d'ailleurs et j'appelle chacun
à regarder la piètre qualité des
amendements proposés de tout temps par
le rassemblement national dans les
budgets que j'ai eu à défendre par
exemple sur le budget de l'égalité femme
homme à l'époque le seul amendement qui
était proposé par le groupe du
Rassemblement national c'était Emmanuel
Ménard et c'était un amendement de
suppression leur seule proposition
c'était supprimer le budget de l'égalité
femme nous verrons mais si tous les
amendements ressemblent à cela il n'y
aura pas beaucoup de débats pour savoir
si on les voit ou pas on va parler
justement des questions de violence
sexuelles et sexistes vous présidez au
sein de renaissance le parti de la
majorité présidentielle la cellule
d'écoute Édouard Philippe dit qu'à
horizon il y aura pas de cellules parce
que c'est pas ou partie de gérer ça mais
à la justice n'a-t-il pas raison
alors nous c'est pas une cellule
d'écoute c'est à dire que nous on fait
pas quelque chose comme ce qu'on fait
les parties d'extrême gauche ou de
laupes puisque ce qui a été fait et
l'image du coup que chacun se fait d'une
cellule d'écoute c'est une cellule qui
étouffe la parole des victimes ou qui
fait des procès stalines puisque ce sont
les exemples que nous avons eu dans les
parties de la nuit parce nous nous
créons une structure et vous avez bien
rappelé son de prévention écoute action
d'abord la prévention c'est que nous
allons faire de la formation tous nos
cadres sans exception seront formés par
un groupe d'experts avec des avocats des
psychologues des juristes des formateurs
et des formatrices face aux violences
sexistes et sexuelles des campagnes de
communication sur ce sujet à l'image
d'ailleurs que de ce qui a été lancé par
ma collègue Sylvie Retailleau dans
l'enseignement supérieur à partir
d'aujourd'hui ensuite il y a
effectivement l'écoute mais nous nous
prenons pas pour la justice nous voulons
orienter orienter vers des psychologues
orientés vers des associations et
surtout orienter vers la plainte moi les
5 ans pendant lesquels j'ai travaillé
deux ans ministère de l'Intérieur tout
mon travail ça a été de dire il faut
restaurer la confiance entre les femmes
victimes de ces violences et l'accès à
la justice c'est ce que nous ferons mais
juste pour qu'on soit clair ça veut dire
que si vous avez des témoignages
contre des membres de renaissance vous
ne prendrez pas de décision comme ce qui
s'est passé à dans les parties de gauche
vous ne direz pas il y a une mise en
retrait d'un tel il y a une démission
d'un tel vous orienterez
systématiquement vers la justice ça peut
être alors il y a les deux en fait et
d'ailleurs le droit est très clair sur
ce sujet dans une entreprise quand vous
avez quelqu'un qui est mise en cause par
exemple pour je vais dire par exemple
pour des faits de harcèlement sexuels
contre une collègue et bien il y a à la
fois une décision de justice et il y a
également une sanction mais là on n'est
pas exclusif de l'autre moi je ne peux
pas entendre qu'on nous dise aujourd'hui
nous ne transmettons pas tel dossier
envers la justice parce que le parti
s'est réuni et nous avons décidé que
telle personne soit été coupable et
devait partir soit été innocente et donc
avait le droit de rester et la justice
circulait il y a rien à voir nous en
revanche nous sommes organisés avec une
commission des conflits donc le la
structure que je préside prévention
écoute action elle transmettra les
dossiers le cas échéant à la commission
des conflits qui pourra se prononcer
pour des sanctions c'est au demeurant ce
que nous avons déjà fait je pense par
exemple aux député Simian qui a été
condamné pour violence conjugale il a
été exclu par la commission des conflits
après condamnation vous savez que la
justice elle prend plus de temps que le
temps politique qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire que vous aussi vous prendrez des
décisions de mise en retrait avant de
décision de justice c'est tout le
problème en fait si vous voulez si la
justice de la justice si la justice se
rendait en quatre semaines et bien aucun
parti politique n'aurait besoin de se
réunir on se dira il y a une décision de
justice et nous nous y fume moi je suis
tout à fait en phase avec ce qu'a dit le
ministre de la Justice la justice se
rend devant les tribunaux je ne me
prends pas pour un procureur et nous
n'allons pas changer la justice nous
allons pas faire une parodie de justice
dans cette structure nous allons
travailler je le disais sur la
prévention et puis ensuite sur l'écoute
et sur l'action sur l'accompagnement la
plainte existe la justice existe des
sanctions pourront être prises elles le
seront par la commission des conflits ce
soir au bureau exécutif de renaissance
je présenterai une feuille de route nous
des discussions et peut-être nous
amendrons cette feuille de route en
fonction ce que nous disent les membres
du bureau de route vous partez sur quoi
sur ces trois grandes piliers d'abord
cette formation qui me paraît
essentielle nous allons renouveler nos
cadres puisque nous avons renouvelé nos
statuts nous avons avec Stéphane
séjourner un nouveau secrétaire général
et donc avec Stéphane séjourner il nous
a semblés fondamentale de faire cette
formation tous les référents tous les
animateurs de comité tous les cadres
seront formés pour savoir comment réagir
parce qu'il y a rien de pire on dit la
parole se libère la parole se libère il
y a rien de pire que quelqu'un qui vient
vous raconter quelque chose et qui ne se
passe strictement rien donc nous nous
voulons aussi informer accompagner dans
l'accès aux droits accompagner pour
chacune puisse se reconstruire ça fait
des mois que j'ai écouté beaucoup de
femmes qui ont été victimes de ce type
de violence en politique pour savoir ce
qu'elles attendaient et quelles
structure nous pouvons construire mais
aussi des avocats nous avons la chance
d'avoir beaucoup d'avocats très engagés
dans vos naissances sur ces sujets et
donc j'ai travaillé avec elle pour être
sûr que nous soyons bien évidemment dans
les clous d'un point de vue juridique
vous citez plusieurs reprises vos
adversaires d'un UPS pensées qui sont
allés trop loin vous pensez que le piège
s'est refermé sur eux mais moi j'ai
surtout été profondément choquée des
propos de Jean-Luc Mélenchon encore ce
dimanche
4mins à revenir à l'Assemblée mais qui
dit surtout monsieur Catena est victime
de gifle politique une sorte de
répétition de gifs politiques qui lui
sont donnés matin et soir dans les
métiers mais franchement mais
aujourd'hui une femme qui est victime de
violences conjugales et qui est membre
de la France insoumise qu'est-ce qu'elle
doit penser quand elle entend ça
qu'est-ce qu'elle pense en voyant la
personne pour qui elle a voté aux
élections présidentielles lui dire qu'en
fait c'est c'est l'homme auteur de
violence c'est très difficile pour lui
qu'on révèle ses faits qu'est-ce qu'elle
entend elle entend taisez-vous elle
entend qu'on a pas envie d'écouter les
femmes alors moi je trouve que LFI
s'enfonce dans l'anti féminisme le tweet
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon le premier on
pouvait éventuellement considérer que ça
pouvait être de la maladresse ou qui
maîtrisait pas bien le vocabulaire
féministe ou qu'il avait fait dans
l'impulsion
guidé par par autre chose mais là il
réitère genre nous on parle plus
revenir à l'Assemblée selon vous c'est
pas mon propos mon propos
c'est dire qu'il y a une justice
d'ailleurs quand les faits ont été
révélés je ne me suis pas exprimée
mais à partir du moment monsieur Bompard
parlementaire LFI a dit que c'était
juste une gifle et du harcèlement
téléphonique et d'autres affaires et que
donc ce n'était pas si grave et qu'en
fait
il y a pas eu de violence depuis un an
c'était un an
et je vais vous dire moi j'ai de la
peine pour les femmes victimes de
violences conjugales quand j'entends ça
il fait reculer la cause je suis pas sûr
qu'il rend service Adrien catenens
d'ailleurs en s'exprime en sans cesse de
cette de cette manière et je pense que
c'est triste aussi pour les féministes
qui sont engagés sincèrement dans la
nuit pêche moi je sais ce que c'est que
aide féministe et s'engager dans un
parti politique et vouloir que son parti
porte des mesures il y a des féministes
qui sont sincères et qui sont engagés
elles entendent Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
elle voit circuler ce projet de texte
sur les réseaux sociaux qui condamnent
le féminisme en tant que tel elle est
fit aujourd'hui est un parti
anti-féministe et il doit revenir ou pas
à sa place vous reviendriez à
l'Assemblée ou pas à la place d'Adrien
moi on peut pas me mettre à la place
d'un objectif de violence conjugale si
vous voulez toute ma vie ça a été de
défendre les femmes face à ces faits et
d'alerter quand j'ai parlé de féminicie
de la première fois on disait que ce mot
n'existait pas aujourd'hui tout le monde
tout le monde l'utilise avec le Grenelle
des violences conjugales on a fait cette
avancée de considérer que oui frapper sa
femme c'est grave et non c'est pas une
affaire personnelle et ben là on est en
train de faire un recul de 5 ans on
revient 5 ans en arrière à une époque où
il y avait pas de consensus pour dire
que frapper sa femme c'était grave on va
parler d'un autre sujet vous avez dit
cette semaine dans un entretien au point
à propos du combat des iraniennes et à
propos aussi de l'attitude de certains
membres de la nuque je cite ses combats
exigent un peu de cohérence on ne peut
pas dire le lundi que le voile est un
embellissement de la femme et le mardi
que c'est un signe d'oppression qui
visait vous avec ses propos
je répondais à une question donc je
répondais à la question qui était très
claire moi ce que je voulais savoir vous
visez certains membres de la nuque
notamment la question qui m'était posée
c'était comprenez-vous que Sandrine
Rousseau était Hué à la manifestation et
donc c'est ma réponse ma réponse est
qu'on ne peut pas dire le lundi le voile
c'est un embellissement de la femme et
le mardi se prétendre porte parole des
femmes qui veulent enlever leur voile
vous avez un double jeu de la part de
certains membres de la nuque de Sandrine
Rousseau il y a une énorme hypocrisie je
vise pas Sandrine Rousseau
particulièrement mais c'est la question
qui m'était posée mais il y a une énorme
hypocrisie de la part de beaucoup de
responsables politiques revenons un an
en arrière au moment des débats sur le
projet de loi pour conforter les
principes républicains quand je dis que
c'est important de ne pas donner un euro
d'argent public aux ennemis de la
République quand je dis qu'il y a de
l'entrisme islamiste quand je dis que
l'islamisme o'prime en premier lieu les
femmes et s'en prend toujours au droit
des femmes et bien certains de ces mêmes
partis politiques me disent oh là là ça
va trop loin il y a l'islamiste c'est
pas si dangereux il y a un discours
relativiste et extrêmement ambigu
prenons les votes de ces groupes ELV par
exemple au Sénat a quasiment
systématiquement refusé de voter les
proposer nous avons fait pour améliorer
la lutte contre l'islamisme radical dire
radicale et donc aujourd'hui
effectivement qu'elle se mette en égérie
des femmes qui meurent pour avoir le
droit de sortir les cheveux au vent je
comprends que les mêmes
du tort pardon à la cause des femmes
selon vous c'est pas une question c'est
pas une question de tort c'est une
question de manque de cohérence pour moi
on est complètement dans autre chose on
est dans de l'opportunisme politique et
dans de la volonté de récupérer des
mouvements et d'ailleurs le peuple
iranien ne veut pas que son mouvement
soit récupéré par des responsables
politiques à qui n'a pas demandé
d'ailleurs de porter sa voix la France
en fait c'est pour aider les femmes
iraniennes ou pour vous ils font en
faire plus je pense que c'est un sujet
très difficile bien sûr la France
condamne toutes les violences bien
évidemment d'ailleurs la ministre
Catherine Colonna l'a dit à plusieurs
reprises
mes collègues Laurence Boon du cadorcet
également à publier une tribune pour
rappeler l'engagement de la France mais
l'Europe doit maintenant aller plus loin
sur ce sujet face à l'Iran c'est le
projet qui est conduit par Catherine
Colonna d'unir l'Europe pour qu'elle
parle d'une voix face à l'Iran et qu'on
soit très clair le courage incroyable
des femmes iraniennes de ses étudiants
aussi que l'on a vu de ces jeunes filles
nous oblige la situation en Iran ça fait
des années maintenant que que beaucoup
de personnalités alertent sur le fait
que depuis 1979 les Iraniens combattent
pas une dictature abstraite une
dictature islamiste des artistes ont
pris la parole Marjane satrapy je trouve
ça l'humoriste kheiron qui a fait un
film sur ce sujet qui s'appelle nous
trois ou rien et d'autres tentent
d'alerter l'opinion publique et bien
aujourd'hui avec avec cette amorce de
révolution je crois que maintenant tout
le monde doit ouvrir les yeux sur ce qui
se passe en Iran oui on va parler d'un
autre sujet dont vous occupez c'est la
question du Bien Vieillir cet après-midi
vous allez faire un déplacement dans le
7e arrondissement de Paris avec le
ministre des solidarités Jean-Christophe
combe auprès de l'association abrapa
comment le gouvernement peut accompagner
les familles et soutenir les services à
domicile écoutez c'est vraiment un enjeu
fort pour nous d'accompagner ce bien
vieillir et de faire en sorte que dans
cette partie de sa vie bien chacun soit
respecté les récentes les récents débats
et je dire ouvert aussi les yeux de
toute la société sur la manière dont les
personnes plus âgées pouvaient être
traitées parfois dans les EHPAD et d'une
manière absolument insupportable nous
parlions du budget tout à l'heure dans
le budget il y a justement sur cette
question de la solidarité des avancées
importantes je vais vous dire nous
créons 4000 places supplémentaires dans
les services de soins infirmiers nous
finançons deux heures de vie sociale en
plus pour que les personnes qui sont
dans ce type d'établissement soit
correctement prises en charge et donc
nous allons avec mon collègue le
ministre Combes auprès de l'association
abrapa qui prend en charge justement ces
personnes âgées qui a un modèle
associatif en tant que ministre chargée
de la vie associative je vais les saluer
un modèle non lucratif et qui s'organise
pour que cette fin de vie soit le plus
le plus doux possible avec des
dispositifs différenciés selon les
milieux milieu rural milieu urbain oui
bien sûr je crois que c'est fondamental
de s'adapter aux spécificités de chaque
territoire et donc évidemment oui ce
n'est pas la même chose selon qu'on soit
à Paris ou qu'on soit en Sarthe dans une
zone rurale ou encore d'abord parce
qu'il y a aussi des
usages différents en fonction des
régions il y a des régions dans
lesquelles traditionnellement on garde
les plus anciens à la maison en tout cas
plus majoritairement et puis il y a
d'autres régions dans lequel on a besoin
d'avoir un accompagnement plus fort
quand la famille pour des raisons par
choix mais parfois pour des raisons de
travail a été éclaté géographiquement et
qu'on a besoin d'avoir cet
accompagnement que vous avez des
personnes qui n'ont jamais de visite de
leur famille oui l'accompagnement social
il est encore plus important ça pose la
question du grand âge évidemment de la
dépendance il y avait une loi qui avait
été promise dans le quinquennat
précédent qui n'a jamais vu le jour
est-ce que là vous dites il faut
s'attaquer à ce sujet il faut une grande
loi enfin sur le grand âge et la
dépendance oui mais je sais que mon
collègue il travaille c'est vrai que
Brigitte bourguignon je salue avait mené
un travail important quand elle était
parlementaire je suis ministre pour
porter justement ce sujet et pour faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une grande loi sur
la question de l'autonomie et du grand
âge c'est fondamental genre la pyramide
des âges aujourd'hui et l'évolution
démographique et sociologique de notre
pays nous oblige à nous pencher sur
cette question et à y apporter des
réponses et reculer dans ce quinquennat
comme ça a été le cas dans le
quinquennat précédent qui sont de recul
c'est il y a une question aussi de
calendrier parlementaire c'est vrai
quand on fait la liste de tout ce que
nous avons envie de porter au niveau du
Parlement c'est très encombré si je peux
me permettre cette expression donc oui
il y aura une question d'arbitrage et de
choix bien sûr de calendrier un mot sur
octobre rose puisque c'est le mois
d'Octobre Rose la lutte contre le cancer
cancer du sein notamment vous étiez
vendredi à Orléans pour soutenir
l'association les bonnes fées et
l'association des Miss France qui nous
guériraient sa maison itinérante qui
propose des soins esthétiques aux femmes
justement qui luttent contre le cancer
du sein que peut faire le gouvernement
pour pour aider pour aider dans cette
lutte pour aider ces associations on
fait beaucoup d'ailleurs c'est en tant
que ministre chargée de la vie
associative que j'ai été à l'invitation
de Sylvie Tellier donc de Miss France
qui a créé cette association les bonnes
fées d'abord en soutien à ces
associations j'observe que quand on est
malade du cancer et j'étais par exemple
à la Ligue contre le cancer des
Bouches-du-Rhône il y a quelques
semaines avec Renaud Muselier pour
visiter justement cette maison consacrée
au bien-être il y a à la fois les soins
médicaux et donc qui passe par les
centres hospitaliers les centres de
cancérologie etc et puis elle
paramédical et là cette association les
bonnes fées ce qu'elle fait c'est que
elle redonne un peu conscience en elle
quand on a un cancer du sein c'est vrai
que notre apparence change les cheveux
peuvent tomber la peau peut être
douloureuse parfois il y a une
masectomie donc on perd un sein on a une
apparence qui change en plus bien sûr de
tout l'aspect médical et les bonnes fait
avec les Miss France bah elle redonne un
petit peu conscience à ces femmes qui
avaient toutes le sourire qui se
regardait dans la glace en étant
heureuse d'être voilà dans cette petite
bulle et ce petit de bien-être avec les
Miss France je vous saluer les bénévoles
qui s'engagent en la matière parce que
que ce soit les bonnes fait la Ligue
contre le cancer et d'autres
associations sont beaucoup des bénévoles
si j'étais liés par exemple à l'étagé à
titre bénévole elle sillonne la France à
titre bénévole et c'est absolument
formidable puisque c'est ça qui donne ce
réconfort à ces femmes et une dernière
question Fabrice
en même temps j'ai un peu du mal à vous
poser une question politique mais quand
même François Bayrou s'est dit prêt à se
présenter en 2027 la campagne est déjà
lancée alors j'ai vu qu'il avait
rectifié ensuite ces propos il a dit que
c'était pas du tout c'est parce qu'il
avait dit
il a démenti en tout cas il a dit qu'il
n'avait pas dit donc
ah non ça y est on est au tout début du
quinquennat non non bien sûr l'assurance
que ce ne sera pas le président sortant
qui sera renouvelé donc forcément ça
crée la Constitution est en scalaire a
priori nous mais on n'est jamais voilà
merci Madame
merci Fabrice on passe au club
[Musique]